l'aide de pain
incontournable des repas en egypte
devenue aussi un indicateur de la crise
alimentaire leurs prix ont augmenté de
25% conséquence de l'invasion russe en
ukraine car l'egypte est le plus gros
importateur de blé au monde et l'an
dernier 70 % de ces céréales provenaient
de russie et d'ukraine
aidé les tue très précisément à utiliser
dans le pain subventionné un pain qui
ensuite à 80 millions d'égyptiens qui
sont inscrits sur des cars de
subventions et donc qui
pourrait ne pas en bénéficier en
quantité suffisante ch'ti on ne trouve
pas moyen d importer du blé la russie et
l'ukraine représente à elle seule un
tiers des exportations de céréales dans
le monde avec le blocage de ces ports le
cren ne peut plus exporter la récolte de
cette année est incertaine et les
sanctions prises contre la russie
devrait perturber les exportations
l'egypte n'est pas le seul pays à voir
ses réserves de céréales impacté le
kazakhstan la mongolie le liban ou
encore la turquie dépendent de la russie
et de l'ukraine à plus de 70% sur le
continent africain les craintes d'une
pénurie se font aussi ressentir en
somalie au bénin à madagascar ou encore
en république démocratique du congo en
tunisie aussi les boulangers voient
leurs stocks de farine ça me nuire les
conséquences pourraient être encore plus
grave au soudan où plus de 85% du blé du
pays provient de russie et d'ukraine
président soudanais sur deux pourrait
souffrir de la faim cette année d'ici la
fin de l'année près de 20 millions de
personnes soit près de la moitié du pays
seront en situation d'insécurité
alimentaire
une insécurité alimentaire qui va de
pair avec l'inflation déjà fragilisée
par la crise sanitaire et l'instabilité
régionale de nombreux pays africains
pourraient voir leur économie sombrer un
peu plus macky sall président sénégalais
mais aussi de l'union africaine a
demandé mardi le soutien de la banque
mondiale et des partenaires
internationaux pour faire face aux
conséquences de la guerre en ukraine il